one we are him from thailand from
germany and with my colleague from a
node we weren't sure if you talk about
haiti one of my first Jobs was in Haiti
in the early 1980s worked on poverty
hunger and whether agriculture I was
deeply impressed by 80s rural
communities but they did with meager
resources investing in the hairs of
their children and education but I was
as many are today deeply depressed by
the government's situation of the
country at that time Tom my colleague
just comes back from Haiti and as one of
the best sources on what's going on now
and how you can help yes you I come over
that I came back to Haiti I have visited
18 45 days out of the earthquake visited
their business I see your concern
worldwide music and we have that our
organization has been working in Haiti
for the past 16 years so when I mean
once there may be our immediate issue
was a hit and make our contribution to
be immediate needs of the people i was
deeply struck by their dignity calm in
the terrible situation but our focus was
getting water to people from beginning
to the shelter situation i'm getting
food and announcements remainder for
entertaining today's i think at this
stage the international community is
beginning to get it back together on the
aid front and I think the initiative
here at the World Economic Forum message
thing together the efforts of the
Clinton Global Initiative the Uni and
the verdict not form is highly
commendable and you did not revise this
both have more naked short term more
specific please
clarifications and the aliens for the
silvered medium to longer term view
again we're in hospital 280 this
initiative is expensive what I learned
here and there was drama is that other
than many of the media reports those who
have been on the ground we're keeping
impressed by the good government
engagement and NGOs and civil society so
I think those who have donated money
resources and I thought about dating can
feel a lot better about the aid reaching
of the pool yes I think some of the
early comments from the press in the few
days after the disaster where I would
say one fair I think there was not a
sufficient to account taken of the scale
of the devastation that affected
countries in terms of the damage to the
government or physical and the people
and the physical infrastructure whole
communication systems were completing
dr. so there was a huge task you with
inevitable that it was going to take a
little time to not to know where to
start get the 8th floor that has now I
think we gonna happen although certainly
not fast enough to really get food more
general distribution of food to the
population okay you know that's where
the Challenger face is saying Angeles I
things UN agencies do you really work
effectively together I think that is a
company that is happening right I'm
honored concerned the next report by
train